ils sont donc les vainqueurs de ce 20è
massique mythe
il s'agit bien sûr de l'équipe de
l'apparence le trophée last à coignières
pour la deuxième année consécutive la
mare au sol remporte le concours
intercollèges d'improvisation le match
était super cool
les e-ticket les autres équipes étaient
super forte et on s'attendait pas du
tout à être en finale et les match était
très serré où on est resté dans le jeu à
fond et puis et puis c'est vraiment à la
fin l'effet de surprise on s'y attendait
pas forcément et on est super heureux
parce que bas sans but c'est la deuxième
année du coup j'ai pas eu grand chose à
faire en vrai un mois je m'asseyais dans
une salle et je les regardais jouer et
ça suffisait largement ils sont tous
très bons
il ya un très bon groupe et ça reste
très important et là franchement ce soir
je pense que les quatre équipes étaient
hyper homogène ça a donné des très
belles rencontres
une victoire obtenue face à une coriace
équipe orr pas yens le collège alexandre
dumas s'incline 3 à 4
comme c'est ma dernière année j'ai kiffé
j'aurais bas je remets c'est être plus
longtemps mais comme d'habitude bas
honnêtement j'ai bien aimé cette finale
franchement même les demi-finales des
touristes et sympathique
on conçoit 2e 4e ou quoi l'important
c'est qu'on s'est bien amusé de
l'improvisation compter à la création
chanter les quatre collèges en
compétition dû rivaliser d'imagination
devant les thèmes imposés
non j'ai dit c'était bien avec mon chien
je veux chercher le fusil
le cercle d'histoire
le podium est complété par le collège
des prés à montigny le bretonneux cette
année 14 collèges sont affrontés tout au
long de l'année des rencontres pour
désigner un vainqueur qui vise la passe
de trois pour la prochaine édition
[Musique]